[Música]
en Colombia el presidente Gustavo Petro
pide acelerar la evacuación de 2500
familias que viven alrededor del nevado
del Ruiz el hecho ocurre el mismo día en
el que el volcán tuvo el mayor sismo
registrado desde 1985 cuando una
erupción sepultó el pueblo de armero
un hombre mató a cuatro niños con un
hacha en una guardería en Brasil el
sospechoso también hirió a cinco menores
el presidente Luis nació Lula da Silva
dijo que era una monstruosidad y
respondió creando un grupo contra la
violencia escolar
El Congreso de chile le dio su aval
final al proyecto de ley de seguridad
naín retamal que le da más libertad a
los carabineros para que usen armas de
fuego Solo falta que el presidente
Gabriel borich firme para que se
convierta en Norma ampliamos desde
Santiago
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
le dedica a América Mi nombre es María
Clara calle
iniciamos en Colombia porque el
presidente Gustavo Petro ordenó que se
acelere la evacuación preventiva de 2500
familias que están ubicadas en zonas de
riesgo por el volcán nevado del Ruiz la
alerta en este momento se mantiene en
naranja y además el miércoles se
registró un sismo de magnitud de 3,9 El
mayor desde 1985 Luis Muñoz tiene más
detalles
Esta es la vista desde el municipio
colombiano de herveo ubicado muy cerca
del volcán nevado del Ruiz que se
encuentra en alerta naranja los vecinos
sienten las consecuencias que se siente
a veces por ahí así algo de ceniza
sí y no se acuesta como nervioso
sienten miedo y piden ayuda yo siento
que en estos momentos nosotros estamos
en una zona de riesgo y necesitamos
mucha colaboración de del gobierno
departamental porque tenemos unas vías
de acceso muy malas para en caso de una
evacuación desde la alcaldía de berbeo
aseguran que están siguiendo todos los
protocolos de prevención
todos los boletines que que nos han
enviado y hemos hecho Pues todos los
protocolos necesarios para el tema de
evacuaciones de albergue de puntos de
encuentro este miércoles el presidente
Gustavo Petro ordenó acelerar la
evacuación de 2500 familias que se
encuentran en zona de riesgo Mientras
tanto el servicio geológico colombiano
mantiene la alerta naranja y la unidad
nacional para la gestión del riesgo de
desastres hizo una actualización
nos preocupa es que en este caso los
sismos cada vez se acercan más al cráter
Y esa según los vulcanólogos no es que
sea la mejor de las señales de hecho
este miércoles hubo un sismo de magnitud
de 3,9 El mayor desde 1985 cuando se
produjo la erupción más mortal del
volcán nevado del Ruiz que dejó más de
23.000 personas muertas
un hombre entró a una guardería en el
sur de Brasil con un hacha y mató a
cuatro niños que tenían entre 5 y 7 años
agresor se entregó después a la policía
si bien tiene antecedentes de agresión
la policía Aún está investigando Los
motivos del ataque Este es el segundo
hecho contra un centro de menores en 10
días por lo que el gobierno de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva está bajo presión
los ministros de justicia y educación se
comprometieron a invertir en nuevos
esfuerzos de prevención de violencia y
el presidente creó un grupo contra la
violencia escolar así se expresó Lula
luego del ataque
Hoy es un día que nos deja a los seres
humanos enojados por una figura que
parece humana tiene cabeza brazos
piernas y ojos pero que cometió una
monstruosidad que todos los que somos
padres madres abuelos tíos nunca
imaginaríamos que pasaría
esta figura humana que no tenía nada de
humano debe haber venido de otro planeta
un planeta del odio humano
estados de Chile un polémico proyecto de
ley de seguridad llamado naín retamal en
homenaje a dos policías muertos esta le
da más libertad a los carabineros para
que usen armas de fuego Naciones Unidas
criticó las reformas advirtiendo que
podrían llevar a violaciones de Derechos
Humanos nuestro periodista Leo honores
nos cuenta más desde Santiago con una
amplia mayoría se aprobó en el congreso
aquí en Chile la denominada ley naín
retamal que otorga mayores facultades en
el uso de armas de fuego en servicio a
las policías la discusión estuvo llena
de polémicas de hecho hubo
emplazamientos de parte de las Naciones
Unidas y también de distintas instancias
de Derechos Humanos poniendo en alerta
el riesgo que podía significar es que
esta Norma avanzara tal como se estaba
discutiendo en la cámara de diputados y
diputadas hasta la madrugada de ayer
hubo negociaciones en el senado en donde
se hicieron importantes modificaciones
por ejemplo se moderó el uso de la el
arma de fuego específicamente de parte
de la policía las denominada legítima
defensa garantizada que era uno de los
aspectos más polémicos también se
eliminó el artículo que permitía a los
oficiales policiales eximirse de
responsabilidades eso también generó una
importante discusión y esta jornada en
las últimas horas finalmente fue
aprobada con amplia mayoría este proceso
ahora qué es lo que resta que el
gobierno eventualmente defina si es que
pone la firma en este proyecto de ley
que estaría en condiciones de ser
promulgado o bien si es que es impugnado
ante instancias superiores como bien
Podría ser el tribunal constitucional un
camino que algunos parlamentarios ya
anunciaron van a seguir
Argentina regresa a una sur y el
presidente de Alberto Fernández pidió
una renovación del organismo el
mandatario viajó a Chile para conmemorar
los 205 años de la independencia de ese
país Desde allí Fernández le pidió a su
homólogo Gabriel borich que trabajen
juntos en reorganizar el bloque regional
para que reúna diferentes ideologías en
Suramérica y a su vez sirva al
desarrollo económico el grupo promovido
por Hugo Chávez entró en crisis en 2017
y 2018 Ahora unasur parece tomar un
nuevo aire con el regreso de Argentina y
Brasil
Mientras tanto en Argentina hubo
manifestaciones en contra de un acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional y
también para rechazar la pobreza y el
alza de los precios aquí los detalles
un reclamo cada vez más frecuente con
más de 120 bloqueos en Buenos Aires y
más de 20 en otras provincias los
movimientos sociales y sindicatos
expresan su descontento con las medidas
del gobierno para enfrentar el deterioro
económico que vivió Argentina las
medidas que está tomando el gobierno
creemos que va a empeorar la situación
porque va a haber un proceso que
profundizará la recesión al
priorizar el pago de la deuda es decir
al priorizar la especulación financiera
la pobreza en Argentina alcanza cerca
del 40% de la población según cifras
oficiales unas 18,6 millones de personas
tienen problemas para subsistir y los
precios continúan al alza con una
inflación anual del 102,5% en febrero
una de las tasas más altas del mundo
[Música]
quitarle la posibilidad de un
crecimiento sano casi 40 por ciento de
pobre millones de indigentes uno de cada
dos pibes con hambre es un desastre lo
que han hecho en este país este siendo
que la gente lo que necesita es trabajo
es necesita poder vivir tranquila y sin
embargo la están colocando en un terreno
de desesperación eso seguramente no va a
terminar bien durante algunos momentos
de la protesta los manifestantes
forcejearon con la policía Aunque nadie
resultó herido
los sindicatos piden que el gobierno
rompa con el fmi con el que acordó una
refinanciación de la deuda de más de 44
mil millones de dólares al tiempo que
convocaron a nuevas marchas para
mediados de mayo
[Música]
presidente de peruano Alejandro Toledo
está una hacia su país de origen este
miércoles una corte Federal de Estados
Unidos rechazó la apelación en la que
Toledo pedía que detuvieran su regreso a
Perú donde está acusado de recibir 34
millones de dólares en sobornos por
parte de la constructora odebrech
odebrecht contrario a lo que decía la
defensa de Toledo la Corte de San
Francisco Consideró que los fiscales
peruanos sí tienen documentos
suficientes para acusarlo el
expresidente fue arrestado en California
en 2019 y desde 2020 ha estado bajo
arresto domiciliar
y en Nicaragua el gobierno de Daniel
Ortega prohibió los viacrucis de
cuaresma alegando razones de seguridad
pero los críticos creen que se trata de
una nueva represión contra la Iglesia
Católica las parroquias se vieron
forzadas a realizar las actividades de
semana santa dentro de los templos y
bajo vigilancia policial además el país
centroamericano expulsó al sacerdote de
panameño donaciano Alarcón medios
locales explican que puede ser porque el
religioso mencionaba durante sus
homilías al encarcelado obispo Rolando
Álvarez condenado a 26 años de prisión
por traición a la patria así se
pronunció la Iglesia Católica panameña
sobre la expulsión del sacerdote Alarcón
Estas son las cosas que a veces no
entendemos de quienes a veces
ostentan el poder verdad y yo creo que
es sobre todo libertad religiosa porque
según lo que pudimos conocer fue
precisamente eso desde después de de la
celebración fue tomado Es cierto que no
le hicieron daño pero fue expulsado del
territorio nicaragüense hasta aquí las
noticias sigan con France 24
[Música]